female breast cancer is now the number
one cancer diagnosis
worldwide what's new for the first time
female breast cancer has surpassed
lung cancer as the most commonly
diagnosed cancer type in the world
denise valdez tells us now more than
ever
women need to do regular screenings and
breast self-exams
now when that report was published in
the cancer journal for clinicians
it was a real eye-opener breast cancer
is more common in women
than lung cancer now remember some
breast cancer risk factors
family history and age for example can't
be changed
but steps can be taken to lower risk
including weight control
limiting alcohol intake regular exercise
and breast cancer screening
patty crowl is a mammography supervisor
at desert radiology
if she knows her own body she's going to
notice those tiny little changes that
your fingers are going to tell your
brain hey back up i feel something
and that's usually the first time they
notice there's something not quite right
it may be benign but it's not worth
taking a chance
it's especially important for women with
dense breast tissue which affects about
half of women under 50. it can make it
difficult to spot cancers on mammograms
it also increases the risk for
developing cancer because the cells in
the glands tend to divide frequently
leading to mistakes or mutations
mammograms are very simple
they're really not that uncomfortable
it's a very short window of time it's
very small radiation
and it can save your life women who've
been told that they have
dense breasts might want to speak to
their doctor about the best screening
strategy for their needs especially
since
other factors like age or medical
history may also impact their overall
risk
for buddy check denise valdez 8 news now